für herten ehre sind es lange tage auf
dem feld in diesen wochen ist erntezeit
der flämische landwirt bringt blauen
kartoffeln ein mehrere tonnen pro tag
wir sind im westlichen zipfel belgien
sind der flämischen provinz westflandern
das besondere in dieser region landwirte
ernten hier nicht nur gemüse sondern
gaben auch andere höchst brisante
kaliber aus herr denn er zeigt uns
seinen jüngsten fund mitten aus seinem
lauf fällt eine granate aus dem ersten
weltkrieg
mein vater hätte sogar gewusst ob das
eine englische oder deutsche ist ich
weiß das nicht
aber diese hier ist nicht gefährlich
vielleicht es noch ein bisschen munition
drin
aber da ist der sprengkopf schon ab den
er weiß eine garantie gibt es nie
solche funde können jederzeit hochgehen
immer wieder kommt es zu tödlichen
unfällen angst hat er keine
so eine kiste voller sprengköpfe gehört
hier einfach zum alltag
das waren noch ganz klein da habe ich
das erste mal so etwas gefunden das war
normal da stand alles noch vom krieg
[Musik]
kaum eine andere region ist vom ersten
weltkrieg noch heute so geprägt wie die
provinz und die landschaft erzählt ihre
eigene geschichte soldatenfriedhöfe
säumen die wege hier entlang zog sich
die frontlinie heutige felder waren
einstmals schauplatz bitterster
schlachten
[Musik]
militärstützpunkt pohl kapelle töten
mayor gino lambrecht plant den morgen
einsatz seine spezialeinheit rückt jeden
tag aus und kriegsmunition zu bergen
es ist erst acht uhr morgens aber hier
in der einsatzzentrale von pool kapelle
erzählt er uns sind schon 30 anrufe
eingegangen
heute haben wir so viel arbeit dass für
mit zwei teams unterwegs sind hier auf
der oberen seite und hier unten dort
waren die deutschen und ihr die briten
die franzosen oder auch belgier
und die hatten alle unterschiedliche
typen von kriegsmunition der fashion's
erster einsatz an diesem morgen eine
baustelle arbeiter sind auf munition
gestoßen jetzt muss sie nur mit seinen
männern ran wir begleiten sie müssen
aber auf abstand bleiben erst beurteilt
die belgische spezialeinheit die lage
dann dürfen auch wir näher an der fund
zwölf deutsche granaten und eine
britische alle stammen aus dem ersten
weltkrieg vermutlich giftgas hier habe
ich eine die noch einen sicherheits
zünder hat daher kann ich sagen die ist
noch scharf die ist noch nicht
explodiert manchmal ist die zündschnur
in so schlechtem zustand
das ist tatsächlich noch gefährlich
werden kann das muss ich alles bewerten
auch der fund toxisch ist oder du warst
im voraus nie was du kriegst daher gilt
immer erst den fund zu beurteilen dafür
sind wir ausgebildet um abzuschätzen wie
gross die gefahr ist wie wir vor ort
handeln müssen das hier ist eine
gasmaske
die schützt uns vor eventuellen
toxischen gasen den kriegsmunition
vorkommen kann
geschätzte 1,5 milliarden projektile
wurden im ersten weltkrieg abgefeuert
die meisten davon sind rund um eva tief
im erdreich begraben
experten gehen davon aus dass 30 prozent
davon noch heute als blindgänger hier
legen scharfe munition austretende gase
vergiften die böden immer wieder gibt es
verletzte
entsprechend hoch die alarmbereitschaft
für die spezialeinheit von pool kapelle
müssen binnen drei tagen das material
bergen so ist es vereinbart zwischen dem
verteidigungsministerium und der
belgischen regierung mit dem fund geht
es zur zentrale 200 tonnen
kriegsmunition kommen hier jedes jahr an
auf eigens präparierten gelände versenkt
das militär die sprengsätze dann lassen
fachkräfte sie kontrolliert detonieren
pol kapelle kann alle typen von
kriegsmunition auf der anlage zerstören
auch toxische in einem aufwendigen
verfahren bestimmen experten die art der
gefährlichen gase um sie entsprechend zu
neutralisieren
zurück im einsatz sergent lambrecht
erreicht wieder ein anruf diesmal unweit
der französischen grenze eine weitere
granate 100 jahre nach dem ersten
weltkrieg ist das tödliche erbe der
vergangenheit für die menschen hier
immer noch realität sie alle hier in
belgien leben mit einem stück bitterster
weltgeschichte tag für tag sowie
landwirten ehre mussten sie lernen damit
umzugehen
jeder auf seine art